former prime minister Imran Khan planned
a protest Caravan across Pakistan
demanding elections beheld a year
earlier and the current prime minister
resign
then on Thursday a few days into his 300
kilometer Journey to the Capitol he was
shot in the leg
the porters say it was an assassination
attempt and blamed the current prime
minister something the government denies
now in stable condition Khan addressed
the media for the first time since the
attack
if this was synchronized I wouldn't have
survived because I fell one of the
shooters thought I'd died and left if
these thieves take control and if we
accept this then this isn't what
Pakistan was made from
Khan was removed from office in April
after a no confidence vote in Parliament
he since held rallies across Pakistan
seeking to rebuild support
imman Khan is our red line and now
they've crossed it we want peace but the
rulers don't want that imman Khan always
advised us to stay calm but now they've
shot him we're waiting for Khan to get
well soon and after that we'll see what
to do
Khan says we have to live and die here
in Pakistan they will run out of bullets
but not PTI supporters
the governing Pakistan people's party is
struggling to bring the economy out of
Crisis something it blames on Khan's
Administration he didn't deliver for
four years the economy was down down the
foreign policy was being challenged all
over the world Pakistan lost its
spreadability
Khan says he plans to join the tens of
thousands of his supporters to continue
the march with the planned sit-in in the
capital once he has recovered
police have lined the streets in
preparation the message is very clear
we're fighting for civil Supremacy in
Pakistan but for the people it's very
important that their voice be heard and
they determine who will be the next
government who will be their next leader
it should not happen in in closed rooms
uh it should be by the vote of the
people
the federal government that runs
Islamabad has indicated that any
deviation from approved protest plans
will be met with Force Leah Hardy Al
Jazeera